son intervention
est-ce que vous pensez véritablement que
les caissières les aident à domicile les
petits smicards
non mais vous rigolez pas à son dans la
capitale vous savez où ils sont
actuellement ils se font la queue au
Resto du Coeur ils sont au Secours
populaire ils n'arrivent plus à payer
leur électricité leur gaz ils pensent
tous les jours à se nourrir mais oui
monsieur c'est ça la réalité de l'avion
que toi peut-être pas les mêmes en tous
les cas vous irez dire à tous ces gens
qu'il faut qu'ils capitalise parce que
finalement vous voulez leur enlever le
régime par répartition à noter que le
gouvernement est contre l'introduction
de cette dose de de cotisation pardon
premier point de divergence pardon entre
la majorité sénatoriale de la droite et
du centre et le gouvernement
[Musique]